hay ocasiones en la vida por ejemplo en
los exámenes a peu en las que se nos
pide describir una distribución en este
vídeo veremos cómo describir una
distribución y más adelante veremos cómo
comparar distribuciones antes de leer el
enunciado y observar esta distribución
veamos qué es lo que necesitamos para
poder describir una distribución hay
cuatro cosas que debemos tomar en cuenta
para esto primero la forma de la
distribución puede ser asimétrica a la
izquierda asimétrica a la derecha o
simétrica podemos encontrarnos con otras
formas pero estas son las más comunes
segundo el centro de la distribución
existen diversas maneras para encontrar
el centro de la distribución ya habíamos
mencionado en otros vídeos que es típico
usar la media y la mediana tercero
tenemos la noción de dispersión para
describir esto usamos el rango podemos
usar el rango inter cuartil también la
desviación media absoluta y la
desviación estándar
todas estas medidas nos sirven para
encontrar la dispersión y cuarto debemos
mencionar si existen o no valores
atípicos en la dispersión
con esto tendremos una descripción
bastante exhaustiva con todo esto en
mente vamos a describir la distribución
que vemos aquí nos dicen el departamento
de control vehicular requiere que los
jóvenes mayores de edad que quieran una
licencia de conducir realicen un examen
de 25 preguntas para aprobar el examen
los candidatos deben responder
correctamente 20 preguntas un lunes 22
personas realizaron el examen la
siguiente gráfica de puntos muestra los
puntajes que obtuvieron los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de describir
la forma el centro la dispersión y los
valores atípicos de esta distribución
creo que muchos de ustedes podrían
calcular los valores de varios de estos
elementos resolvamos esto juntos veamos
la forma de la distribución notamos que
la mayor parte de los datos se
encuentran en el rango de 20 a 25 pero
tenemos esta larga cola a la izquierda
lo que nos dice que esta distribución es
asimétrica a la izquierda ya encontramos
la forma de esta distribución es una
distribución asimétrica a la izquierda
ahora veamos el centro de esta
distribución podemos medir el centro
usando la media o la mediana para
facilitar las cosas aquí usaré la
mediana hasta cierto punto podemos
calcular la a simple vista y también
podríamos usar la media aunque nos
llevaría un poco más de tiempo yo creo
que la mediana se encuentra en algún
lugar en este rango pero vamos a
calcularla tenemos 22 datos la mediana
tendrá 11 datos a la derecha y 11 datos
a la izquierda veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 y 11 la mediana
aquí está en el número 23 y vemos que
hay muchos datos con este valor si
ordenamos estos datos 11 de ellos serán
iguales o menores que 23 y los otros 11
serán mayores o iguales que 23 si usamos
la mediana nuestro centro es 23 vamos a
escribirlo pues decidí usar la mediana
para calcular el centro de esta
distribución ahora veamos la dispersión
la forma más sencilla de medirla es usar
el rango que calculamos restando el
valor menor al valor mayor
rango es 25 4 igual a 21 aquí usamos el
rango porque es muy sencillo de calcular
aunque podemos usar otras medidas para
encontrar la dispersión finalmente con
respecto a los valores atípicos la forma
de identificarlos es subjetiva algunas
personas pueden no estar de acuerdo si
este punto de acá es un valor atípico o
no pero yo pienso que estos cuatro
valores de aquí son valores atípicos así
que tenemos en mi opinión
aproximadamente cuatro valores atípicos
en resumen el objetivo de este ejercicio
es habituarnos a pensar en estos
conceptos
la estadística busca encontrar y
desarrollar formas diferentes de
calcular y de escribir mejor el centro
la dispersión y la forma pero por el
momento vamos a habituarnos a
identificar estos elementos y con esto
terminamos